antes de la próxima alerta estos
bomberos voluntarios están recibiendo su
nuevo equipo mejoras que han sido
posibles gracias a las inversiones del
gobierno pero también a las generosas
donaciones del público en general estos
fondos se utilizaron para comprar nuevos
cascos y algunos camiones nuevos como
éste
ahora sabemos lo devastadores que pueden
ser estos incendios estacionales y estoy
seguro de que volverá a ocurrir en el
futuro espero que al menos hayamos
aprendido algo de ello de todas formas
ahora tenemos muchos más bomberos
experimentados que saben qué hacer en
este tipo de situaciones se pueden
permitir que incendios tan feroces como
los del año pasado vuelvan a ocurrir la
respuesta es sí para la comisión
parlamentaria de investigación que se
creó para investigar el asunto para
evitarlos aconseja entre otras cosas
acercarse a las comunidades aborígenes
tienen sus propios métodos para prevenir
la propagación de los incendios
forestales esos métodos se han
transmitido durante generaciones para
combatir un fenómeno natural y
estacional en australia edwin xavi es un
experto en el campo está mostrando el
uso de un fuego de control tradicional a
varios bomberos estos incendios de
pequeña escala y baja intensidad ayudan
a limitar el riesgo de incendios durante
la temporada de incendios de arbustos y
contribuyen a la regeneración del suelo
conectivo no sé
figura el entorno con incendio demasiado
intensos sólo se evita que las hierbas
altas vuelvan a crecer durante un tiempo
no se quema la tierra se le alimento
cada vez más bomberos pero también
granjeros llaman a estos expertos
aborígenes en incendios para que
aprendan sus técnicas todo el mundo gana
aprenden de nosotros y nosotros
aprendemos de ellos de hecho estamos
uniendo nuestros conocimientos están
noveles para los que viven en zonas de
alto riesgo los incendios del año pasado
fueron un punto de inflexión a netgear
pasó la noche del año nuevo de 2020
protegiendo su casa de las llamas
después de perder casi todo comenzó un
trabajo costoso para hacer su casa más
resistente al fuego y cambiamos todas
nuestras cercas y reemplazamos las
viejas de cercas de madera por unas de
metal que deberían ser capaces de
soportar el próximo incendio un enorme
muro de contención de madera también
tuvo que ser cambiado reemplazamos todo
por piedra porque la madera y el
mantillo se queman muy fácilmente y
sabíamos que si había otro incendio se
quemaría una y otra vez pero estas rocas
nunca se quemarán
pero apagar las llamas no es suficiente
esta es una de las advertencias de la
comisión de investigación que establece
un vínculo muy claro entre el
calentamiento global y la frecuencia
pero también la violencia de los eventos
climáticos extremos todavía hay
demasiada gente que discute el vínculo
con el cambio climático o la actividad
humana estén de acuerdo o no no me
importa
debemos cambiar en nuestro estilo de
vida para sorpresa de todos los
incendios del año pasado también
destruyeron algunos de los bosques más
húmedos del mundo que normalmente no se
queman un símbolo del cambio climático
que ha despertado a la población según
el ecologista marc graham significa una
parte importante de la sociedad se
escandalizó y esto hizo que cambiara su
opinión sobre los incendios y las
emisiones de carbono
desafortunadamente para mí todavía no
hay suficiente gente que haya escuchado
el mensaje
el gobierno de scott morrison es acusado
de no hacer lo suficiente para combatir
el calentamiento global esto se confirma
en el último informe publicado por
climate transparency con unas emisiones
de co2 per cápita tres veces superiores
a la media del g20 australia es uno de
los mayores emisores de gases de efecto
invernadero del mundo nuestro gobierno
está bajo la influencia de la industria
de los combustibles fósiles
es una relación incestuosa corrupta y
escandalosa
claramente hace nuestro futuro mucho más
incierto porque es como echar leña al
fuego el gobierno ha minimizado
constantemente los vínculos entre los
incendios forestales y el cambio
climático no solo la comunidad
científica sino también los bomberos de
alto rango están pidiendo una acción más
decidida para proteger el medio ambiente
de lo contrario en el futuro se
producirán más incendios violentos que
destruirán ecosistemas milenarios como
este
no podemos decir que todavía son bosques
y su estructura ya ha sido profundamente
modificada iba a tomar décadas incluso
siglos para que se recuperen porque
estos incendios fueron particularmente
violentos y lo que estamos viendo aquí
es una imagen de nuestro futuro y no es
bonito
los estigmas de esta temporada que los
australianos llaman el verano negro aún
son muy visibles pero en canberra el
gobierno hace oídos sordos a las
críticas de parte de la comunidad
internacional y se niega a establecer
objetivos climáticos más ambiciosos la
señal sin duda de que el mensaje enviado
por esos terribles incendios aún no ha
sido escuchado